good morning John while you were
spazzing out on bike trails in
Indianapolis this week I was having one
of the coolest days of my life
actually talking to the people who are
constructing the James Webb Space
Telescope and I was doing it with some
of my very favorite people my wife
Michael Aranda ends a freaking Frank's
day by the way is as hilarious in person
as he is in video form what kind of car
does this turn into is this a Republican
or a Democrat like a crazy game of
racquetball in this room returning soon
to online video youtube.com slash is a
Franck subscribe today about a year ago
I made a video about the James Webb
Space Telescope project that I believe
to be one of my generations greatest
contributions not just a science but to
the world NASA apparently freaking loved
it they tweeted at me they started
telling everybody that they were
increasing awesome and decreasing
sizably what I'm saying is it got passed
around like in the offices of NASA and
NASA contractors and a guy Lockheed
Martin showed it to Jeff grant who was
the vice president of Space Systems at
Northrop Grumman but at Northrop Grumman
they just call him the vice president of
space he emailed me and asked if I
wanted to come actually meet through the
people who were working on the project
and I was like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I would yeah yeah on a related note John
I would like to propose that my title at
vlogbrothers enterprises be changed to
Hank green president of space
nerdfighteria with that can I be
president of space hang out a North
Grumman was crazy
because there are people following us
everywhere we were constantly monitored
meaning that I was entirely unable to
hump anything which is really
disappointing and I apologize people
followed us to the bathroom of course
the people following us around isn't
because they were trying to protect a
Space Telescope it's because Northrop
Grumman makes most of its money making
tools and weapons for the United States
military hard science versus heavy
weaponry kind of different you know
missions but a lot of NASA's contractors
are also defense contractors and while
the mission thing is different maybe
even antithetical it's time to figure
out who's going to build an incredibly
advanced one-of-a-kind piece of
machinery whether it's designed to bring
the world together by exploring the far
reaches of our universe or you know to
blow things up the technical challenges
are surprisingly similar weird which is
life
important to note that science and
engineering and technology are neither
good nor bad it's just how we as a
society decide to use them but people we
we are both good and bad and I can say
having met the people at Northrop
Grumman Space Sciences Division
those are good people some of the
smartest people in the world and despite
the fact that they work for a big
bureaucratic organization they were
really fun to hang out when they had a
lot of really nice things to say about
nerdfighteria which that's a short path
to my heart for me the Webb telescope is
a culmination of all of humanity's
progress up to this point like it's the
most technologically sophisticated thing
we can do but for the people who've been
working on it defending it from Congress
overcoming technical challenges day in
day out it's easy for them to lose sight
of how amazing the work that they're
doing is so I feel really good that I'm
able to bring that home to them and to
the rest of the world and just talk
about these big cool things every
civilisation passes things down through
the ages that we all marvel at and
wonder at and say how did those people
do that how could they be capable of
that and I feel like the Webb telescope
and Hubble
that's our pyramids that's the thing
that we pass down that future
generations are going to say Wow
they they work together they got
together and they did that thing and it
was amazing and I think that I got to be
there and to meet those people I'm very
grateful John I'll see you on Tuesday
and of course the bigger reason why I
was there we were filling a bunch of
content for scishow so you should go
subscribe to scishow if you want to see
Hank green and say Frank talk to
Northrop Grumman scientists about the
James Webb Space Telescope and other
projects that they're working on at
Northrop Grumman trust me you will not
regret it
dftba